it's something tonight ccsd leaders took
two very small steps toward reopening
schools
superintendent jarrah and the trustees
will allow the return of small groups
on a voluntary basis sasha loftis
joining us now and sasha parents for the
most part are saying
this really isn't going far enough
[Music]
denise and brian yes the parents i spoke
with say they want their kids back in
school
sooner than later now the steps that the
ccsd trustees
made today are just as you said a small
step forward really laying the
groundwork
for schools to eventually reopen
the clark county school district is
taking small steps
towards reopening schools i am worried
about their education i feel like
they're getting cheated
it's a decision many parents call long
overdue
after months of distance learning
struggles and trustees
previous moves to delay any action the
younger kids just
it's really hard not having
that teacher or that assistant there
just to keep them on track
two votes were passed during thursday's
regular board meeting
the first approved an agreement with the
clark county education association
to lay groundwork for an eventual k
through third grade hybrid transition
i believe that we should really focus on
a plan let's get some sort of plan in
place
and then continue working on distance
learning
the second which was unanimous will
allow principals to bring
students who need extra support back to
campus
in small groups on a limited basis
because there's no such thing as a
comprehensive plan and i think that we
all know that
being adults that said we need
i think we need hope there's still no
word on a timeline
but families tell us they want to see
concrete change
so their kids can succeed
now experts also said during tonight's
meeting that 90 percent of ccsd schools
assigned more
failing grades this year than last
that's part of the plan behind that
option for principals to bring smaller
groups of students who are students who
are struggling back to campus
so they can get that help when needed
for now reporting live tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now